There are three issues that
I want to bring up. Uh,
as I begin today's lecture that will
determine my general themes today,
improvisation,
the international dimension that the
fiction of the novel acquirers and the
influence of art or,
or of literature on reality.
Those are the general topics
as,
as we move to the
conclusion of the Quixote,
the issue of how to bring the novel to
a close most have loomed large in serve
anthesis mind.
The plot of a novel is repetitive more
than sequential with the vague quest of
the protagonist to revive the age of
chivalry and concretely to participate in
the joust and said,
I've also as goals, uh,
but there is no obvious or impending goal.
Uh, do the character's wonderings. Uh,
although one could argue with Williamson,
the critic I mentioned in the last
lecture that the disenchantment of Deucey
Neha is the main purpose of Don Quixote
and essential set by Merlin's prophecy
and involving the 30,000 lashes that
sanctuary most applied to his bottom.
And the interplay between the two about
accomplishing that goal of is enchanting
Lucinia.
Uh,
yet even this is no clear mission,
who's accomplishment would
bring the novel to an end.
Uh,
why did Gutierrez disenchanted?
How could she be disenchanted?
What would that mean?
Would she ended donkey healthy then Mary,
this is not mentioned by the
protagonist nor his marriage.
Normally a desired end to courtly love.
Love itself is the,
is the purpose of Courtney
love the love of Luff. Um,
it is overused that the only and the
possible would be the death of Don Quixote
making his life the shape of the
fiction though which life would be the
question? Is it the life
of our loan Suki high? No,
the Bidalgo who went mad
and became donkey haughty,
but about his early life and family.
We know next to nothing.
We only know about his knees.
Then later we learned that the
niece was the daughter of a sister,
but we really don't know
anything about his life or easy.
The life invented, uh, by donkey haughty.
The would be night errand.
Uh,
would that be the life that comes
to an end to close the novel?
Yeah.
Improvisation. I have been
saying all along since two room,
the plot of the Quixote serendipitous
actions provoked by chancing counters on
the road and by characters who pop up
in the second part wanting to script the
knights life or it meets at
least episodes of the night life.
What role will improvisation
play in the ending of the novel
then you said confluence. Oh, we will.
We will be talking about that or we'll
be seeing about that in the next few
lectures on us.
We come to the very end of the novel and,
and discuss that there is a confluence
of actual geography with current
historical events. Uh, flip,
just the expulsion of the Maurice Course,
bringing in Catalonia and the Turkish
and Huguenots ministers in the final
episodes of the Quixote.
These events,
the returners us to the beginning of part
two and the discussions of donkey hot,
a ducky hope.
This house about some of them,
particularly the Turkish threat.
Okay.
This is a form of, of closure
to this return to those, uh,
discussions at the beginning of part two.
The novel acquires an international
dimension announced by Don Quixote.
The priests don't Sandstone Carrasco
talking about the Turkish threat in the
early chapters.
I see Don Quixote.
We're going after all to
try to resolve that issue.
But notice the concurrence of
real geographical settings.
We spoke of the Ebro River and now we
have Barcelona with historical actions.
We have, uh, uh, today,
uh, Elena apple juice.
And I produced the
slightly primitive map of, uh, of Spain.
But I think that it is clear enough to
give you a notion of what I'm talking
about.
But of course you have a real map of
Spain in the website that you can,
uh, you can see on your own. Um,
I wouldn't be a alluding to it.
Uh,
so we have seen the able to
river Barcelona we have now,
uh, and we now we'll see
historical actions, uh, involving,
uh, that region. Um,
now the,
none of the historical actuals that,
uh,
appear in the hotel.
By historical,
I mean current historical events.
Okay.
None is more current and pressing
than the expulsion of the Maurice goes,
which is taking place as sort of amp.
This is writing
part two.
The topic of the expulsion centers on the
character of early [inaudible] day and
his family,
he is one of the principal new characters,
uh, in part to the international
dimension of the novel,
allows Advantis to introduce fresh carrots
of characters who are different from
those mainly Castilian ones that he
has presented so far though as we know.
And I'll talk about it again,
not exclusively Castilian
that's the second of the broad topics.
And the third is the one
about art influence reality.
In several of the of these
episodes that I will be discussing,
particularly the one involving
two fellows, but also in others,
there seems to be at decided influence
of art on reality and a coalescence of
the two by which one could
say that reality or the real
is improved by art as we
have already seen in other episodes
before. But we'd have some, uh,
today or where that seems
to be, uh, the main topic.
Yeah.
Now, uh, let us begin with ricotta.
Uh,
one could say that this
story is a rewriting of the
captives tail from part one
with a ricotta whose name is Anna Feliks.
That'd be talking about
his name and let me know,
recalled the name given to his daughter.
Her name is Anna.
She will be the Aida of this
rewriting and Pedro Gregorio.
Her suitor would be the captive.
But I mean this is,
well these are,
these two episodes are very
different at the same time,
the one of the captive and the
one involving, he caught it,
or at least the record,
the episode is much richer in some
respects under the captives episode is,
it's quite elaborate
in these last few chapters of the Quixote.
Cervantes appears to be offering many
possible variations of narrative fiction
or some of the narrative,
uh,
modes available to him at that moment.
Uh,
did he go and his family provides the
opportunity for Emini Novella Morris or
more mortgage novel
and Noella Mariska is a
tale about the love of a,
between a Christian Young
man and a morrish young woman
with all the predictable
obstacles.
The best known of these,
the whalers Maurice because is called
after its prototype. Prototype.
Dentists' mean?
Uh Huh.
And this novel is embedded in
Degooseman Guzman. They'll farace.
I won't put the name on the board
because you've heard it many,
many times during the semester.
The,
all the other fictional mode in this,
a kind of smorgasbord of narratives
is the Byzantine Romance,
the Byzantine Romance,
which entailed drawn out adventures
over vast geographical areas,
adventures of lovers seeking to
find each other and suffering.
Abductions chipped rex and being lost
in strange lands only to find when they
finally meet that unbeknownst to them,
unbeknownst to them,
they are brother and sister
and cannot marry. This is a,
it's a kind of, uh, Ma, uh, of
romance Britain at the time.
A very convoluted,
hence Byzantine.
Uh,
now Cervantes was writing such a romance
as he raised to finish the Quixote.
It's called law.
Strava hosts see lists.
He see his moon though the trials of
pedasil lists and see he's Mukunda.
Okay.
We will be revisiting this when we
talk about the prologue to that work.
Uh, which are Avantis thought would be the
culmination of his life, of his career,
but he was, he was wrong. Uh,
a very interesting idea that I,
if criticism has taken it up would be
to study the influence of the writing of
the trials of Perseus and see his
Miranda on part two of the Quixote.
As these were books that
[inaudible] worked on all
the same time towards the end
of his life,
he's rushing to finish the Quixote and
rushing to also finish the trials of
[inaudible]. And it will be interesting
to see how much one influences the other.
But here I said, we mentioned
it a little bit. Uh, he,
they influence is,
is obvious.
Ana and Pedro's abduction by the Turks
and their c journey and rescue are like a
small scale Byzantine romance that
is played out in front of the port of
Barcelona. This is like a
Byzantine romance in a nutshell.
They are abducted by the
Turks. They're going away, uh,
they finally meet and uh,
there is no ending to it. Uh,
uh, because you said Maurice God, she
cannot come back to Spain and all of that.
But that is a kind of a
little Byzantine Romance. He,
Larry US tidbit, if you have
already read this in this story,
is that Anna eager to protect pedal
from their abductors and Pedro is a very
beautiful young man,
dresses him as a woman to make
him less attractive to the Turkish
copters.
It is a comic dig at the
Turks whose alleged sexual
proclivities we're notorious
and are even mentioned in good
old [inaudible] is Tesoro.
In the entry on the Turks there is a
not so veiled allusion to this very
practice. Dot. Cervantes
is alluding to in a very,
uh,
I think comical way.
It is kind of a transvestite.
It isn't to the second power or
something like that to somebody.
Why Advantis wanted to provide this
smorgasbord of narrative possibilities at
the end is a mystery to me.
One answer is that,
uh,
other than just a boast of artistic
mastery is that he's consciously seeking
variety in his work and he is aware and
has been since part one that for all the
possibilities of his newly found hero
donkey hold this adventures good,
become monotonous and decided to include
this technical extravagant extravaganza
as a kind of overture or something.
This accumulation of narratives is also
a sort of a closure by accumulation,
what could say. But, uh,
US get back to recording first,
let us consider the name.
Click coating.
Grieco means rich in Spanish being rich.
Rico
can be all day.
Okay.
Is that now we've been tative Indian
ending that increases something.
Remember that I mentioned this
at the beginning of the course.
Okay.
goto.is a big fat. So no,
uh, so Ricotti is, uh,
me and said he's very
rich, which, which he is
though some claim.
Some critics claimed that hidden names
derives from his being from the value of
Ricotta Evalyn [inaudible] name.
But I, I don't buy that. That is,
I think a little bit, uh, to uh, Ooh,
tangential. It's obvious that he's
recorded because he's very rich and, uh,
we know that about that because he talks
about the treasure that he has buried,
um,
now was really caught the Cervantes
passes judgment on a current event,
one that is taking place as
he writes the book there.
Maurice costs where it's spelled in 1609,
it's bullshit.
Well, the whole process lasted
several years. So remember,
these are the years when he is writing
this book. If you read your Elliot,
you will know that a long debate
proceeded the expulsion as there were many
people against it,
mostly for economic reasons
there Maurice,
because we're an integral part of the
economy of several regions of Spain and
had some clout in the government.
Your expulsion as you have learned in
earlier cost ruin in some areas of Spain
as the expulsion of the Jews in
1492 had also brought about, uh,
all kinds of dire consequences
to the, to, to Spain.
But he's a confluence,
a coalescence of the text of the fiction
with current history that we had not
seen before in part one or even part to
marine any other fiction anywhere with
the possible exception of the goose man,
they al Farace.
But there it is not as explicit.
Um,
the events that are mentioned are
not as dramatic and as current as the
expulsion of the Maurice costs.
Now this,
the fact that the story will
eventually remain on finished.
Remember they have to put a petition to
Madrid to have Anna Felix a pardon for
returning to the peninsula.
She,
she faced with the possibility of uh,
of being sent back or even
of being executed. Uh,
now the fact that the store
would be remains unfinished
leads me to think that's
an advantage is considering considering
here how closure can be brought about in
the story that blends with ongoing time.
How can you bring closure to a story
that deals with something that is in the
process of happening?
How can fictional time offer closure to
stop something that is happening in real
time?
If you do that,
a closure will be a way of
fictionalizing what is real
by giving it a,
an artistic shape.
So this is a theoretical issue that
I'm sure was a in Cervantes is mine.
And if you remember in part one,
the very last of the stories
is also left unfinished.
I will take this up again as we
consider the consider the ending of the,
uh,
of the novel.
But what is the meaning of all of this
business of current events in, in,
in terms of surveys as his opinion
about the expulsion of the Maurice Course?
This has been,
as you can imagine,
a hotly debated issue with presentism
play a heavy role in the debate.
Presenteeism is a way of
alluding to a form of criticism,
a bit of literature or,
uh,
an interpretation of history
that favors depressant.
You interpret the past in
terms of the precedent, uh,
or you project the present into the past.
Of course,
the issue is whether one can
completely avoid this ever.
But there are some critics and some
historians who exercise this, uh,
to the point where it's, it, it
is, uh, uh, obvious that it's the,
that is not right.
And a lot of presentism has played a
role in this debate about what is the
advantage really favored or not.
The expulsion of them are east coast,
all of these colored by
all of the 20th century,
particularly debates about minorities
on their roles and so forth.
In other words,
some critics want to make this into a
contemporary and having a spouse views or
modern liberal thinker.
Okay.
Uh,
Cervantes is obviously appalled or the
expulsion of those Maurice Ngos who were
obviously part of the
fabric of the country,
those who have truly converted,
but I think he gets,
he tries to give it balance,
a balanced view of the whole thing.
Obviously worried about an internal enemy
to the state given the international
situation.
It is possible and it has been mentioned
that he was also worried about himself.
Uh, if you express an opinion,
obviously opposed to that of the crown,
but think of this,
Morocco is a barely across
the Strait of Gibraltar.
Yeah.
I'm sure that most of you know
that area of the, of the world.
If you have seen Casablanca, which is
not there, but nearly not nearly enough,
but I don't know where the young
people like you have seen that classic.
But in any way, you know, this
is the Strait of Gibraltar,
Spain and Morocco is here.
So Morocco was in the hands of Nms of
Spain of the same race and religion as
their Maurice costs.
In other words,
as opposed to the Jews who
had been expelled in 1492,
the Maurice goes,
had an international projection.
They potential international projection.
They could be allied with foreign
enemies and become a fifth column within
Spain. Fifth column is
red. You say about how, uh,
a group of individuals who are against a
government but living within the state,
within the niche.
There Maurice goes as the episode
of the captive in part one.
Uh,
the Maurice goes a allude
with their presence to one
of the central myth for the
constitution of modern Spain after
the unification of the country under
Ferdinand and Isabella,
the reconquest meaning the recovery of
Spanish territory from Morris Control,
which culminated with a fall of Granola
in 1492. What do you mean by this?
Is that the Maurice
Coast? Uh, we're a, uh,
uh,
with a very presence,
recalled the presence of the
Morse in Spain or two 1492.
And the Reconquista,
the reconquest that becomes sort of a
central patriotic myths that helps paint
together. So, uh, uh,
so the Maurice goes or expelled in 1609,
appealing to people's fears dumped the
reconquest could be undone and hence her,
the whole country would collapse.
This is ridiculous of course,
but governments do tend to, uh, to uh,
motivate the populace with such fierce,
particularly totalitarian
governments, uh, do that. Uh,
Hitler, uh, did, uh, in Cuba.
Fidel Castro has been how's bring the
impending invasion of the Yankees for 50
years? It has never come
to keep the people aroused.
And this is what is happening
in the span of this moment.
The Maurice Course called somehow unleash
a counter or conquest and bring the
whole country down.
Now,
in terms of the part of our protagonists,
Loki Hotel on central,
the relevant thing is that here we
observed central making difficult and
delicate moral decision
with respect to recording the decision
is whether to help him and he is in need.
And they got, they also offers
him a very substantial, uh,
material reward or tool for law,
for Sandra to be loyal to the
king by obeying his edicts.
Okay.
Sanchez, uh, memories by the way, uh,
play a part in the episode episode.
He recalls crying when he got his family,
left his town and reveals that
Anna Feliks has Pedrog ago.
Greg, you in my, your ass go as his
suitor. Am I your escorts or word?
You already know? Private ordering
audio is not only a Christian Young man,
but a very well to do Christian Young man.
Okay.
Sandra chooses a middle ground.
He will not help regarded
dig up the treasure,
but he will keep silent about record
this illegal return to Spain and his plan
to take the money out of the country,
which is also illegal.
There were heavy sanctions against taking
money out of the country because with
the expulsion, uh, as always happens
when, when, when, when a certain,
certain people are expelled from the
country and they'd take the richest,
this affects the economy of the country,
uh, tremendously. So there were,
there were, there were
laws against, uh, the, the,
the Briscoes taking their wealth
with them too. So record tay is,
is guilty of,
of two crimes having returned and
also planning to take money out of the
country. Sanctuary, uh, makes,
uh, a very, uh, difficult, uh,
decision because he
himself is taking a risk.
If it is learned that he
has not, uh, uh, uh, uh,
report it, you, this
return, he could be, uh,
also held responsible.
Now we've got the himself is a complex
character and he's one of the few figures
not marked at all in any way in the book.
By complex,
I mean that he's caught in conflicting
dilemmas and is able to weigh different
of view.
He is comparable to a hemo Morrato.
So riders father in part
one, but here this is a, uh,
more, uh, this is
expanded, uh, because Eh,
he's, he's, he's wife is
converted to Christianity.
His daughter was born into Christianity.
He has not quite converted.
He is in a very difficult, uh, situation
three.
Got The sense that he's not against
the edict of banishment of expulsion.
You understand the reasons
of state behind it,
but laments that even those Maurice
Co's who have joined the main stream of
society,
even converting to Christianity,
are paying for the actions of those who
are seditious and with whom he does not
agree.
Santo confesses to his neighbor
in passing and just marvelous,
uh, postprandial, uh, or, uh, uh,
exchange they have after he and the
German beggars and all of that get drunk
with their wine and eat and so forth.
Uh,
Santiago confesses his travails as a
governor announced to the ability for the
position and Rick [inaudible],
who is clearly better
educated than Antonio.
Uh, and, and,
and can tell that the whole thing had to
be a hoax does not press the matter in
this recorded this place,
a deeper human understanding and four
barrels for the shortcomings of another
human being's Saint Joe's ignorance.
So it is a very subtle touch
on the part of [inaudible].
There's a certain neighborly complicity
by which the figures of Saint John
recorded around the house
filled out.
This choir is growing intellectually
and spiritually. Uh, the normal, uh,
uh, progresses. And
Rick got the, as I said,
uh, it's, uh, it's a very, uh,
complex and well rounded character
who goes through a very dramatic,
uh,
process here.
My friend did distinguished a Puerto
Rican scholar, Lusail Lopez Bharath.
Okay.
Professor at the University of
Puerto Rico has written eloquently.
He's an Arab east,
has written eloquently about the Maurice
goes on the literature they produced.
Learning about it may
help us understand better,
regardless plight as depicted
by surveying this in the hotel.
I'm referring to a,
uh,
a study by Lopez Barel and title.
What image did the Maurice goes
have of themselves to rights?
If I were to symbolize the fundamental
in image of themselves or the Spanish
Mariko's had, I believe that
the epithet used by [inaudible],
she's writing about,
uh,
the episode used by man what would be
the most appropriate criers or we purse
when Maurice goes being deposed
by the authorities cried.
Instead of rewriting elegant
passages from their literature,
they were determined to preserve for
posterity a faithful image of themselves
and how they reacted before the historical
crisis that was coming upon them.
Then she adds,
and this is precisely what Maurice call
literature is about because there was a
Maurisco literature.
It constitutes a literary monument to
the collect collective effort to preserve
at all costs,
Islamic identity mortally wounded
in the Spain of the golden age.
It was an enormous effort because the
basic elements of Islamic culture,
the language, proper names, distinctive
dress, religious ceremonies,
even the Zumba dance had been strictly
forbidden by numerous official decrees
issued all along the 16th century
or code she yards finally,
but these very same Maurice course
divided in the deepest recesses of their
souls found themselves
before a new dilemma.
When Phillip the third
decreed against them,
the order of expulsion in 1609 they had
not been allowed to become bona fide the
Spaniards in their country of origin,
but they did not have time either to
become authentic Muslims during the first
decades of their exile in Barbary,
the Maurisco community went through two
different processes of assimilation.
Their Islamic identity had been torn
from them forcibly in the span of a 16th
and 17th centuries.
And when they finally in Marist in the
process of assimilating themselves to
official Spanish, they were forced by
circumstances to begin another process.
Now, the opposite, one of
cultural assimilation. Encore,
in other words,
as you have read here,
when they went back to
their countries of origin,
what countries of origin there were from
Spain, they found that they were not, uh,
uh,
accepted in the Muslims communities
where they thought that they would be,
uh, uh, welcomed and where they would
be able to blend themselves into the,
into the mainstream. No,
they were exiles again, uh,
within their own people. They
were in a no man's land. Uh,
culturally speaking,
this is the drama that recorded
and his family is living through.
And [inaudible] is mentioning here.
In short,
what's Advantis accomplishes in the
episodes involving ricotta is to provide a
view the vision of the
effects of political decisions
made with concern for the
nation as a whole on the people that
are affected by those decisions.
The normal is not a treatise on political
philosophy nor is that a commentary on
government policies.
It is a medium through
which the particular can be
perceived in the lives of
specific people.
Of course,
what's advantage is dealing with here
is an issue that has affected that
humanity since time in memorial and that
would continue to affect it until the
president til today,
until the issues that we're
facing in this country today,
it is the presence of minorities within
a body politics and how a state can deal
with them without endangering its
own existence. More broadly speaking,
the issue is how nations and states
define themselves negatively as that which
they are not and try to wage wars against
real or perceived enemies and cleanse
their own population of potential internal
enemies that maybe accomplishes of
external ones.
This seems to be a content in human
history and one can see its manifestations
in the bible and classical literature.
The modern history of abuses provoked
by these tendencies is long and shameful
from the expulsion of the Jews from
Spain in 1492 to the extermination of
millions of the,
by the Nazi regime in Germany,
in the Spain that we are studying.
It was not only their Maurice course
that did not fit within the homogeneous
body of the nation.
Gypsies convert souls and the people in
regions such as Catalonia and Galicia
who were out of sorts with
the Castilian driven state,
Catalonia Galicia of here.
Uh,
we have seen through the
chaotic characters from other
provinces like the bask,
the Galicians,
the historians.
Spain is a country divided against
itself and continues to be.
So if not Google Eta the
Basque terrorist group,
the basket terrorist group that uh,
whose activities center all over
it. But I mean they are in both, uh,
uh, uh, uh, Spain on, uh, um, France,
uh,
because that's where Basque people live
and have lived there since the beginning
of time. They have no idea
where their baskets came from.
Their language is not in the European,
they have no idea where it came from. A,
so they are separate. It's uh, on, on,
on the extreme group,
the terrorist group ETA is
a fearful fearsome to both
the Spanish and the French
state.
Uh,
Cervantes Hot Bay is the first substantial
work of fiction that dramatizes this
conflict.
And the regard,
the story is the most dramatic from
the point of view of literature.
The thing to keep in mind is that the
conflict involving the expulsion of the
Maurice Cosi seen in its particulars,
not in general terms.
And that is poignancy is due to the
believability of the characters,
especially recorded,
but also in the tenderness,
the neighborly solidarity
that he and to display.
These are human qualities and emotions
that are beyond political policies.
And the novel will from now on,
always be about them.
This particular,
not the general theories,
so,
so much for recording and Anna
Feliks for the time being,
we may have to return to them,
but now little fall into
the pit with central. Uh,
I, uh, uh, I assume that
you have read, uh, this, uh,
wonderful, uh, chapter, uh,
in which central falls into a pit,
uh,
which is a symmetrical episode
two, the Montesinos Cave, uh,
uh, adventure, uh, of
his master Don Quixote.
There is an internal parallel by means
of which Cervantes parodies himself
within part two.
I had told you their episodes in part
two that are repetitions of episodes
within part two. This episode is a
parody of them Montesinos Kate Cave,
which was itself a parody of several
ci Valerie episodes as well as,
uh, others. Uh, that'd be
salting homer virgin on Plato.
These lifts sanctuary kind
of equality with his master.
It is a funny one, but nevertheless,
it is any quality with this master.
It is to be noted.
However,
the central falls into the pit cave
after losing his island fall of Troy,
uh, an ess as dissent. Uh,
there is a kind of pattern here.
I have a series of quotes
here that I want to gloss,
uh, from, uh,
an excellent article written jointly by
Raymond McCurdy and Alfred Rodriguez.
And,
uh,
I will quote them and glossed them
as I did with the Lopez burnout as an
internal parallel. They say the
series of actions that we study,
meaning the fall into the pit, uh,
have exceptional characteristics.
It is in the first place,
the most prominent example
of the deliberate parallelism
that largely structures
that Quixote,
the parallel in which the
obvious resemblance that
strikes one is the set for
common subterranean stay.
He's talking about the cave in Montesinos
in this parallelism, the parallelism.
He quotes, they quote one
Marasco who says m. I. R. S. Oh,
we notice the correspondence,
the striking parallelism of cycles
in part two and Chapman of Dulcinea,
like the loss of Troy, the sent
to Montesinos Cave. Uh, this,
the infernal descent of a
[inaudible] central banks are losers,
is loss of Troy falls into a deep and
very dark pit in third oldest sent.
So you can see that they have all,
they have noticed this
parallelisms in great detail.
They add the parallel that
we're studying by offering it,
offering a curious parody of a parody
becomes a mirror that reflects the entire,
that reflects their advantages entire
creative process because this is a parody
of a parody,
the parody of Cervantes himself.
Okay.
Cervantes. They say producers in
with a central Pantheon adventure.
Now you can make central
bank sign an adjective,
at least for the reader who picks up
all the hints thrown by the novelist and
innovative. And at the same time
Snyder re parity double pouty.
By doing this,
the great novel is touches on purpose.
The aesthetic limits of his own artistic
procedure for would appear to be the
limit of parodic creation,
a limit insurmountable and innovative
self parody that is more over at parody of
a parody.
This is the reaching deep into that series
of images that are repeated deep into
that mirror.
We see each other in the barber shop as
a little boy when you're reflecting over
and over and over and over
and over and over and over.
Now we also notice now, uh, having
abandoning Mokodean [inaudible],
uh,
that this episode,
it involves this in Ganja.
We just,
which makes sense to even more reflective.
And he no longer yearns for the island.
Uh,
he values more his service and
his attachment to Don Quixote.
He yearns for the intimacy
of their relationship.
Now they are then because doc,
you hope they fines Saint Joe because he
has gone out to practice for this joust
he's encounter,
he's supposed to have.
And by chance a hero Saint
Joseph's laments, uh,
and that encounter is going to be the
one to restore Donya Rodriguez daughter's
honor by having the young
man, uh, uh, uh, uh,
who promised to marry her and,
and uh,
compromise their honor.
Uh, go ahead and marry her.
So here we have,
we go to that third of the topics
I had mentioned in an instance,
an instance of art influence in life.
The prank organized by the Duke and
his minions brings about the possible
marriage of the young woman to the young
man who plays the role of her strange
fiance because it is no longer
the real fiance who's involved,
but it's someone who's
playing the strange fiance.
These adventure will turn out like the
loft conflicts of part one that don
Quixote salts, except that here
the fiction is turned into reality.
Whereas in the Doterra
Fernando Panda Philando affair,
the giant is only symbolically slain
fiction and reality are no longer separate
in part to their part
and parcel of each other.
Fiction does not simply reflect
reality. It affects, affects it,
it affects it.
Fiction and reality appear to be
one and the same or in other words,
reality is nature improved by art.
In the episode we have again in marriage
where social mobility is involved
[inaudible] Rodriguez,
his daughter was going to
marry up economically because
he's young man was alive,
but the groom's proxy Tostinos
isn't me or servant a lackey.
She however concludes that is better to
marry the not at all and accepts him in
a,
in a gesture of,
of pragmatism that is
completely at odds and funny,
but it's completely at all through all
of the notions of idealized love that we
have here. She sees that the
better to get married, uh,
done not to be married at all in a
situation in which you used. And in the,
in the context in which she finds herself,
that is an echo here.
I find that a very
funny one, suddenly, uh,
about the fights about to begin and this,
this,
this proxy a groom looks at the woman
on falls in love with her and said,
oh, I don't want to fight. I surrender.
I'll marry her. And in the end
she says, okay, I'll marry him,
buried him that nobody and a,
and this is what it's funny.
So the fiction becomes the reality
that is the fiction, whatever.
It's very obvious that it's an
echo here of Camacho's wedding.
So in a sense,
the 70 is also repetition of it
let be sold in part to like, uh,
Sanchez for,
uh,
in the cave of Montesinos adventure.
But the point is that fiction has improved
reality and this is a theme that is
repeated in the next two episodes,
or at least cost very briefly,
but they are very significant.
The first and most commented about is
when they find this images of [inaudible]
Rick saints covered
with sheets on the road.
These episodes just remind people of
the one towards the end of part one.
When the penitents carry an image of the
virgin remembering the procession and
don't Quixote takes her to
be a lady in distress here,
us with the actors in the wire
of death episode and uh, uh,
he makes look here that makes no
mistakes. Uh, actually he does a, uh,
quite an area died. Uh, uh,
a study of the image of a
Saint George don't get halted,
knows that these are
representations clinics have
seen in this episode echoes of
the debates involving erass mutants
and those was Protestant [inaudible]
leanings about images and other devout
representations in this episode.
If you've read in the
earlier and you know, uh,
there was a whole debate about whether
they should be religious images in the
churches are not, of course, uh,
the f the faction in favor of religious
images, obviously one in Spain.
Uh, but there was a debate.
It involve Erasmus too. Uh,
but the point is that reality here
appears to have turned into art.
What he finds on the road are already
representations of the saints are artistic
images of the saints there.
They're out there.
The second episode,
which I find most charming,
he's going to be sad when Don Quixote is
caught in a net in a green net that was
set there among the trees to
capture birds by this, uh,
by these young ladies playing
a being shepherded, says,
and getting ready to perform
an echoed by Gfsi Lasso.
That port I've mentioned so
many times in the semester,
and that I hope you remember his name. A
cloth is pastoral pawns. They're about,
they're about to stage one of
them. They have learned, uh,
the lines and all of that.
She says, and Oh, Quixote, uh,
valves to stand in the middle of the
road and defend them for however long it
takes. And, and, uh, so
reality again, appears as art.
Young women dressed,
as shepherds says about to stage a,
an heck log by the Great Garcia lastro.
Notice that guns last one sport.
It has to become a part
of common discourse.
It has improved common everyday discourse
is young ladies want to represent his
poetry.
Gutsy Lasso.
Remember 1501 1536 only
35 years you lived.
But when he's spoke, his poetry
was published in 1543 posthumously.
It changed poetry written in Spanish,
Spanish language forever until today.
That's how important he was.
But notice that his poetry
has been incorporated into
everyday life by this. Uh,
so we conclude by talking
about rocky generic.
Rock agnostic is a Catalan bandit who
really existed and lack the Maurice cause.
He brings out an international
dimension to the novel.
Bringing the edge of this
kind was coming in Catalonia.
There were bands of brigans like this,
which the crown felt
that it had to put down,
not only because they were outlaws,
but because they could become a
competences of the French Huguenots.
Now notice again the map we have here.
Now location of the Maurice Course.
We had the threat of the, uh, of,
of Muslims across the,
the Strait of Gibraltar here.
Catalonians right next to France.
And in some ways it's
more French and Spanish,
certainly more French than Castilian
and the language and all of that, uh,
and has been very successful.
Just like the Basques
do the two today,
the Catalans,
the Catalans think that
they have their own culture,
that you have their own nation,
many of them do and so forth and so on.
And this and this,
or this band,
it's like a rock could be in
cahoots with a French Huguenot.
You're going not where
the French Protestants,
you get notes where the French
Protestants with the Calvinist background,
uh,
who believed in the,
they good attain salvation without the
intervention of the church who believed
in reading and interpreting scripture
directly. Typically the things that these,
the, the Catholic church rejected
violently, especially from Spain.
So Huguenots were dangerous also,
Spain and France and France had been
at all throughout the 16th century.
So the French were no
friends of the Spaniards.
And so the Spanish crowd feared this,
uh,
Catalan bandage because they, they
could be agents of the French Huguenot.
Remember what I said about states
defining themselves negative,
what they are not or the Spanish
crown was not was Protestant for sure,
or not French and not muscling,
but rocky. He not, he's a
compelling attractive figure.
Cervantes was fascinated by the
autonomous world of the bandit and by his
chivalry abandoned lack.
Croaky invents himself on
the margins of the law.
There is something romantic
of aunt Lola in rocky.
He anticipates the bandit figures
who are heroes in 19th century,
uh, normals, John Paul,
Joan and all of the dollars.
Ginardis a kind of Catalan Robin Hood who
rubs the rich and helps those in need.
He's Lawler's except within the
very strict laws of his band.
I you saw how strict they are.
One of his,
one of his associates
questions to division of the
booty and he'd be heads him.
Um, in this respect, rocker
is like money, Paul, the you,
uh, and his brotherhood and
bring Canadian quarterly. Yo.
His band is an anti utopia that counter
society as self enclosed world built
from within itself
is goodness possible
within an outlaw society.
Goodness always appears,
possibly. Serratus.
Remember Buddy Doremus
who is good to others,
she's kind to century and also reliable
within the practices of her profession.
Perhaps not about trade, even if her
profession is being a prostitute,
but she delivers,
he's Canard and new exemplar of the
heroic that's advantage can never stop
dreaming about you see
an exemplary manner.
Arms as opposed to amount of letters
is Dennard donkey Hotez counterpart.
Is he not a modern night errand of sorts
is, isn't this what makes him
attractive to Don Quixote?
Notice that the tricky treat
each other with respect.
That donkey haughty knows about the
existence of Ragnarok and rocky NART seems
to have read or heard about part one of
the Quixote because he also knows about
a donkey hoppy. So, uh,
there is a kind of self recognition
parallel to the one we find in the episode
with Cardinia.
We're Gnocchi hold defines Gardenia.
And they have that meeting where they
looked at each other having the uncanny
feeling that they,
they know each other.
And here we're not
guilty meets rock in art.
We have the same kind of recognition
of mutual recognition. And,
and, and I know you because
I know myself kind of.
So that is rocky nerd who makes possible
donkey holders entry into Barcelona
because this bandaid is in touch and has
influence with the important people in
the city of Barcelona. So, uh, uh,
Doki holder gets it the kind of safe
conduct from the band to enter the great
city of Barcelona,
but not before.
We cannot conclude without mentioning an
episode within the episodes of rock or
you're not. And it's not about Claudia
heroin, Nema, Claudia. Hey, don't EMA.
Claudia had only man in Claudia had
on him. And we have yet another story,
another love story with a lady in
distress because her lover seems to not be
willing to marry her because there
is a class disparity or something.
But Claudia had only my takes
drastic action by killing her fiance.
Don't be sending who's a potential don't
Fernando who or in his death row swears
that he has been the
victim of, of, of, uh,
of rumors that he has not unfaithful
to cloud your heroin. In my,
to late Claudia had only
mom took care of him. Uh,
uh, this is the one of these, uh,
instead of Antin 17 women
characters who, who, uh, who, uh,
wants to, uh, to take her
destiny into her own hands,
she goes to a little too
far here. Perhaps, uh, uh,
it is a piece of the bullous they come
at you because of the death scene,
but with a different and
very tragic ending here.
Uncharacteristically tragedy
occurs before marriage,
which is unusual tragedies in
the golden age and Golding,
each Spanish literature tend
to happen after a marriage.
And we don't know if it is just another
instance of Cervantes taking episodes
from part one where we even within part
two and taking them one step further
in the next class will
be taken about are uh,
talking about our protagonist
arrival in Barcelona,
also about [inaudible] spurious Quixote,
which by now has appearance.
Cervantes knows about it. And
which resurfaces in the, in the,
in the, in the scene of their
visit to the printing shop.
And also we will talk about Doki
holders, final defeat. But I want,
I want you to take, uh, uh,
to pay special attention,
uh, to LTC Laura's dream.
I'll teach you Dora,
is this, this, uh, uh, very, uh, uh,
active young lady with
an active imagination and
proclivity to acting and all of
that who has a marvelous dream,
uh, in, in, in one of
the episodes when, uh,
Don Quixote and Saint Joe go back
to the Duke and Duchess Paris.
And, uh, it's a, it's an episode,
her dream in which the whole issue
of books will resurface again.